this lima woman is saying we're what
non-human
indirectly but if the galaxy comes to
believe their leaders are less than
rather than more than themselves they
may cease to follow
hey guys pete here this is my foundation
season 1 episode 4 breakdown barbarians
at the gate bounces back and forth
between trantor and terminus but we do
get a glimpse of our narrator and a
promise of finding out what happened to
her at the very end in this video i'm
going to recap everything that happened
and get into what it all might mean but
i do have to give you a quick spoiler
warning if you haven't watched episode 4
yet this video won't be for you with
that out of the way let's get into it
the episode opens with teenage brother
dawn remember this was the baby who was
presented at the ascension ceremony
timeline wise he was born 19 years after
the starbridge bombing and then there
was another 17-year time jump so we're
36 years on from harry selden's trial to
sync things up with terminus it took the
colonists roughly five years to get
there and now they've been settled for
30 more there's a bit of narration here
with gail reinforcing the idea that
psycho history only predicts the
movement of masses and not individuals
and it all tends to reinforce the idea
that this particular clone of cleon is
different in some way which could
probably cause a problem for a
predictive model that supposed that the
emperor would always stay the same
regardless of that there seems to be
something wrong with them he climbs out
on his balcony and with a painful look
on his face throws himself off the edge
there's a young gardener there working
who witnesses his fall as his protective
aura device saves him from becoming a
blood stain what he was trying to
accomplish isn't exactly clear the young
gardener gets scared and runs away that
leads to a side story where he looks
into her and ends up spying on her after
she gives him a tip about using a
medicinal plant called wolf's breath her
name's azula she's been working in the
garden since she was a teenager and it
seems like she might be important later
we check in with brother day who's with
the courtesan it gives us an insight
into how he experiences pleasure and
sexual satisfaction and a little bit
more about how their protective auras
work before he can satisfy his
physiological need for intimacy demarzel
interrupts because the proxima opal is
passed this is the leader of a religious
space and it sounds like a powerful one
considering it has trillions of
followers there's a potential problem
here because there's a new candidate who
has a chance to take over that follows
something called the primary octavia
this is a pre-imperial belief that
centers around individuated sentience
long story short as clones the cleons
could be viewed as less than human
brother day explains it to dawn he says
if the galaxy comes to believe that
their leaders are less than rather than
more than they may cease to follow so
there could be a legitimate threat to
their power and brother dusk plans to
visit the conclave in person to address
the situation even though all this time
has passed since the starbridge attack
on trantor they're still unrest and we
see there's an uprising in the lower
levels from the heatsink workers and the
cleons also learn about a communications
buoy going offline in the outer reach
this prompts brother day to bring up
terminus and the exile of harry selden's
followers there they have problems with
the conclave there's unrest at home and
now there's problems in the outer reach
he asks his brothers if they're starting
to see a pattern forming harry selden
laid out these very problems that
they're facing now and at that time
brother day didn't do anything about it
because he saw him as a charlatan so
there's a rift forming between day and
dusk the older has a reason to stick to
what he did back in the past even in
light of all these new events starting
to look like harry's predictions are
coming true
the current brother day summons the
royal master statisticians to ask them
about what they've learned about harry
sultan's math they've been working on it
for three decades now and still don't
really understand it they believe the
predictive models are counterfactual
because since he made his predictions
the empire has expanded rather than
contracted in every meaningful metric
when pressed though they can't say that
there's a non-zero chance that he isn't
right about everything in frustration
day goes and calls out dust for his past
mistakes with an acrion thespis and
terminus he says he's not going to let
him make the same mistakes and says that
he'll go to the conclave instead
demerzel steps up and interjects that
the primary cleon has never left trantor
at any time in the genetic dynasty but
she isn't able to change his mind so
dusk throws it out there that his
brother is haunted by selden's ghost and
then he's sent back to trantor where he
summons someone to go investigate the
boy going dark in the outer reaches and
he tells him that the dispatches from
the foundation have become sporadic pay
them a visit and tell them the empire
won't be kept in the dark so they'll be
heading to terminus we visit there and
pick up with salvor who ran into those
enactions in the remains of the slow
ship they've been on the planet for a
while scouting and their story is that
they're looking for the navigation
module from the ship they get salvor to
take the leader through the fence
because she wants to go to the tower in
the center of the city it works out that
she's only able to get the one person
through so the others tell her if she
doesn't return in the time a watch is
passed they'll raise the city to the
ground on the way salvor has another
vision and makes a move towards the
vault where the gnawfield knocks her
captor out she takes her prisoner and
figures out that she's the grand
huntress which gives them leverage they
can't really decide what to do with her
and salver thinks they need to get ready
to defend themselves she tries to get
information out of pharah because she
believes the navigation module is just a
distraction she shows her that she can
predict the outcome of coin flips to
sort of psych her out and through the
scars she has in her fake eye puts it
together that she must have been five or
six when she survived the empire's
attacks on her planet salvor realizes
where her resentment against the empire
comes from it's from losing her mother
and her brother and she tells the others
that she senses a deadness inside her
that she wants everyone to die
salvor talks to the encyclopedist louis
parine and you get a better
understanding of why he disregarded her
in the last episode this idea he has of
her being an outlier comes from the
connection to the bolt which he says is
something that couldn't have been
predicted through psycho history after
all it can't account for individuals
he goes to talk to pharah who mostly
ignores him and this insistence he has
that they're backed up by the empire she
says all of them have been exiled and
they're all dying just at different
speeds and she points out that harry
prophesied that the fall would begin at
the edge of the galaxy in their
conversation it starts to become clear
that they destroyed the buoy and landed
on terminus to get a response from the
empire they're just trying to provoke
them but it isn't clear what they're
after or why they think they have a
chance against them the people on
terminus start to realize that there's a
lot of an acronym surrounding the city
and when silver goes outside she has a
different kind of vision this one's
pretty vivid she's in the imperial
library and almost looks like gail at
least the clothes she's wearing and she
sees the boy with rach's knife again
she's able to talk to him this time and
says i won't hurt you just tell me who
you are and there is no answer and all
of that starts to convince her that it's
coming from the vault she tells hugo
this he says that she's special and that
he has absolute faith in her
pharah starts to convince lewis to help
her by telling him that they are
technologically bankrupt ever since
their atmosphere was set on fire she
continues the story that they need the
navigation module because they have
ships but can't make their way to a
different system to rebuild their
civilization as salvor's watching the
troops outside the fence assemble a
weapon she thinks there's a larger
strategy at play here but she can't
figure it out the vault isn't an acronym
or alien at all she believes it's from
harry but she has this crisis of faith
that maybe lewis is right maybe her
being an outlier is the reason that
things are going wrong and maybe the
visions are warning her to stay away
hugo counters this by saying what if you
are seldon's plan which i guess you
can't blame him for not understanding
how this works and picking up on the
fact that there is something going on
with salvor we leave them and in the
closing moments we see the cryopod
holding gale moving through space and it
approaches what looks like a spacecraft
as it cuts to black and the episode ends
there so there's a couple of things
happening on trantor something's up with
the new brother dawn brother day is
starting to think of harry selden's
predictions again in light of the new
crises that are emerging and brother
dusk is trying to defend the decisions
he made 35 years ago it's interesting
but it feels like it's taking its time
getting wherever it's going the
religious angle is essentially brand new
so i'm not sure what to expect with day
heading to the conclave the terminus
side of things is mostly the same as
last week the enacrions are there
there's a split in how they should move
forward salvor is having visions and i
wish i could say it got more compelling
as we're watching it unfold but this
episode didn't feel like a big leap
forward the thing that's most
interesting here for me is what happened
to rach gail and harry and it all kind
of undercuts the current events salvor
brings it up in this episode when she's
arguing with louis that harry says the
foundation survives the first crisis and
that makes all the running around in
circles a lot less dramatic i felt a
sense of relief when brother dusk
ordered the guy to go to terminus
because i think salvor is probably
correct that that's what an acrion is
trying to do so let's get there there's
a problem baked into a story that's
built on psycho history how do you make
it exciting when someone already figured
out how the future is going to play in
the beginning azimoth jumped from one
crisis to the next until it got
predictable and then he found different
ways to mix things up there were
different scenarios that came up as the
new civilization was developing the tv
show seems content to take its time and
present a lot of mysteries along the way
but even though everything's connected
it doesn't always feel like it so it's
promising to see that we get a glimpse
of gail here at the end because maybe
understanding what's going on there will
add to what's happening on terminus give
it a feeling it's going somewhere the
ideas of belief and faith are all over
this episode you have the populace's
belief in the genetic dynasty you have
that being backed up by the religious
leaders the cleon's faith in their
purpose and the encyclopedist faith in
harry selden all of that is being called
into question and then you have salvor
she's on the opposite side of the people
on terminus she's not so sure how she
feels about just sitting back and
believing that harry's plan would have
figured this all out but then she's also
having this personal crisis of faith
that's getting in the way of her moving
to try to figure out what to do with the
enacrion hopefully next week we'll see
how that plays out and what that'll mean
for the rest of the season last week i
decided to hold off on doing another
book to show video because i thought
there would be a lot of overlap with
this week there's a moment in episode 4
where salvor uses the saying that the
character is best known for in the books
violence is the last refuge of the
incompetent it's both a nod to the
source material but also kind of a wtf
moment because it points out how
different the show's version is so i'll
get into that in my next video i'll
discuss the changes that have happened
in episodes three and four and what i
think it means for how the story is
going to play out because i do think
this is a good place to leave this one
so let me know in the comments what you
think's going on what you're hoping to
see please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already thanks
for watching i'll talk to you soon